[موسيقى]
لقد أثبت حدث الأمس ما نحن عليه طوال الوقت
ويجادلون بأن العمل العسكري ليس بالضرورة هو العمل
وفي الوقت الراهن، يعرض العمل العسكري المختطفين للخطر
وهذا ما نراه وللأسف تلقيناه بالأمس
دليل رهيب على ذلك ولكننا نرى
ومنذ انتهاء الأنشطة، لم يغادر كل من هناك
الخروج على قيد الحياة يثبت فقط ما نقوله
ونحن نعرف أيضا من هم
في تجربة المختطفين الموجودين في التجربة
أن فعل اللون قد يعرضهم للخطر ولكن بالتأكيد
حان الوقت للتكثيف لأننا في الغالب نطالب
الترويج لصفقة والتوصل إلى صفقة وقبولها إذا لزم الأمر
قرارات شجاعة إذا كان عليك اتخاذ قرارات شجاعة
نرجو أن يتخذوا القرارات الشجاعة للوصول
من أجل صفقة شاملة
وأصدرت "المخطوفون" الآن استطلاعا لمواقف الفلسطينيين
في يهوذا وشمرون بخصوص حماس والحرب روب
عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين في يهودا والسامرة
والذين من المفترض أن يكونوا إداريين، فإنهم يدعمون دعم حماس
غير مؤهلين أكثر بكثير مما كان هناك دعم
في حماس حتى الحرب، أعني أننا بحاجة إلى ذلك
افهموا أنه في يهودا وشمرون سيكون علينا أيضًا إجراء تغيير
عمق الموقف من هذا النظام ثم إذا كان هناك أي
الانتخابات وسيختار شخص آخر ثم سيكون لدينا
الشرعية أنت قناع غليظ مليئ بالرحمة لا لا
معاذ الله أن تكون لدينا الشرعية لقول ذلك
ليتو باس ليس السلطة الفاسدة ما هذا
سلطة جديدة أخرى إذا كان من المحتمل أن تكون هناك انتخابات
حماس ستفوز بهم، وهذا ما لا تريده إسرائيل
سيحدث ذلك، لكنني لن أكون قادرًا على السماح لقناة حماس بالبث التلفزيوني
الانتخابات هي حرب في غزة بين إسرائيل وحماس
أو ضد ديسيل لا يغير أي معاناة عسكرية
زيادة الدعم لحماس بشكل منهجي حسب الحاجة
أن نفهم في هذه الحرب أنها ليست حرباً بين
الدول هي حرب بين دولة ومنظمة
الذي يطمح إلى دولة ويرى نفسه حربا
أن هذه المنظمة، آسف، هذه الأمة لن ترفع علمها
بالنسبة للأبيض والأبيض هناك صورة للنصر في هذه الحرب
لا توجد صورة للنصر بالمناسبة، البعض منا يتوقع صورة
البعض منا يتخيل النصر
س إها
خرج سنو أهيا سنوار أ ويداه مرفوعتان
من الشريط سوف ينتقل إلى حيث سيذهب أو يعود
روحه الخالق ليس لها راية بيضاء في الحرب بلا
سنستدعي والشعب الفلسطيني يكافح من أجل الوصول
الاستقلال لن يكون موجودا، لأن 18 السنوار لن يكون
ويعيش السنوار حيث سيتم إطلاق سراحه من السجن حينها
وقال إن هدفه هو تحرير كل شيء
الفلسطينيون المشويون ولكن في الواقع الهدف الحقيقي
هدفه هو البقاء على قيد الحياة هذا الهدف الحقيقي لتلك الحركة
الخمسه مستمره من 87 مستمره عندي